hey everyone I am really excited to be
up here talking to you today about
browser extensions we're going to talk
about what they can do some of the
challenges my team faced when we built
ours and most importantly what all this
has to do with sandwiches but first let
me introduce myself my name is Shannon
capper and I'm a front-end developer
here in Seattle a startup called tex do
so to explain how i got wrapped up in
the wonderful world that is browser
extensions i should tell you a little
bit about what i do so this is tex tio
we're an Augmented writing platform that
lets you know how your language is going
to perform as you're writing we give
your document a score we use highlights
to draw your attention to key phrases
and we suggest replacements for
troublesome language now notice here
that we're writing a recruiting mail but
as you can imagine this isn't really the
ideal user experience for writing email
it's pretty disruptive to have to come
over to our website to write your email
and then copy and paste it into your
actual mail client to send it ideally
we'd want to bring our Augmented writing
experience to you and the places that
you would normally write and that's why
we decided to build a browser extension
so basically we wanted to build
something that looked like this this is
someone else's page and someone else's
email editor but with all of the text to
a UI that our users know and love so
this was the challenge before us and all
of it was theoretically possible using a
browser extension but what actually is a
browser extension out of curiosity by
show of hands how many of you use
browser extensions on a regular basis
basically everyone okay now how many of
you know how to actually build one
that's actually a pretty good number so
I mean you may be smarter than me but
like I use browser extensions all the
time and I had no idea how they worked
until I actually started building one
and it turns out they're pretty
straightforward a browser extension or
plugin is just a small piece of software
that runs inside the web browser modern
extensions are built with HTML
Javascript and CSS so if you're already
used to doing web development this
should be right in your wheelhouse and
there's even a standardized web
extension API that's backed by w3c and
that API is supported
Chrome Firefox Opera and edge and notice
how I don't say Internet Explorer or
Safari they do support extensions but
their setup is completely different so
you won't be able to easily share your
code between them and the others so at
this point you might be asking yourself
well what can a browser extension do and
you know what that is the wrong question
the question you should be asking is
what can't a browser extension do
because these things are crazy powerful
and frankly it is kind of terrifying
knowing all the things they're capable
of
for example an extension can yield lots
of control over your tabs it can open
new ones it can read which ones are open
currently and it can close them if it
wants to
so popup blockers are a good example of
this they monitor your open tabs and
they detect and they close any that they
detect to be pop-ups we can also make
Network requests and add an icon to the
browser's toolbar so for example mail
checker will regularly ping a server to
see if you have any new mail and if it
detects oh you have new ones it shows
you how many you've got we can also read
modify and add to the Dom of any webpage
and this can be used in a whole bunch of
really creative ways this is a video of
Google Translate extension which can
detect when you make a selection read
the selected text from the Dom and adds
a tooltip to the page to show you what
the translation is super cool another
example of a plug-in manipulating the
Dom is my personal favorite
it's called Millennials to snake people
and it is awesome what it does is it
finds any instance of the word
Millennials on the page and replaces it
with the word snake people to great
results like this
so here the plug-in is actively
modifying text nodes put into the dom by
the host page and that can be really
dangerous but we'll get to that later
so to go back to our earlier question if
bars or extensions can do-- they do all
these amazing and powerful things than
what can't they do and the list is
pretty small first they're tied to the
browser so the browser isn't open the
extension can't run pretty obvious but
worth calling out next you can't just go
changing your permissions willy-nilly
you have to declare which pages you want
to
run on in which parts of the web
extension API you want to access that
way when a user downloads your extension
they kind of know what they're getting
themselves into and if you want to go
change those permissions later on the
extension gets temporarily disabled
until the user agrees to the new ones so
I mean hopefully you're all honest
people who like don't want to go
sneaking behind your users backs but you
know even if you did the browser
wouldn't let you so probably the most
important thing that an extension can't
do is it can't directly interact with
the host pages JavaScript when an
extension is running on a page it's in
its own isolated environment it can't
see what the host pages javascript is
doing and the host page can't see what
the extension is doing they actually
don't even share the same window object
and well is this sometimes a problem for
the most part it's a good thing a
Cascadia js2 years ago while on the
speakers noah adams talked about the
challenges of writing third-party
javascript and one of the things he
called out was dealing with a polluted
window object the host page might do
some bad monkey patching or they can
define node module code on the window in
a way they would interact badly with
your code and the good news is that we
don't have to deal with any of that
because we're in an isolated environment
so under the hood a browser extension is
made up of four parts there's a manifest
file which contains some metadata and
specifies those permissions that we were
talking about there's a pop up which can
be invoked by clicking on the extensions
icon in the browser's toolbar it's like
a little self-contained web page of the
extension owns there's a background
script which runs headless Lee behind
the scenes whenever the browser is open
and it isn't tied to any one tab and it
has access to the full web extension API
and then there are the content scripts
and these run within the context of a
specific tab and they can talk back and
forth of that with the background script
if you're used to seeing server client
architecture diagrams you'll notice that
this looks pretty similar so these
content scripts are the ones that can
interact what's it done and then we're
gonna focus on for the rest of our talk
but let's get back to our story my team
decided that we wanted to build a Chrome
extension to make it easier to use text
eel while writing email we decided to
start with just Chrome because that's
what most of our users
and we knew we could easily extend out
to other browsers if we wanted to in the
future so short term we wanted to bring
text EO to recruiting mail and supported
email clients namely LinkedIn recruiter
and Gmail but long term we wanted to
build something that we could extend as
text EO grows to bring text yo
everywhere that you could write on the
web so now that we know all the powerful
things an extension can do it should be
pretty straightforward to make this
picture a reality right no no it was not
straightforward at all it turns out
writing JavaScript that runs on someone
else's page is way harder than writing
JavaScript that runs on your page as a
browser extension you have no control
over the page you can't control how its
laid out you can't control what it's
code does and you can't control how it
handles user actions and every single
page is different not only that but it's
also super easy to abuse your power and
change things in a way that breaks the
host site so to protect ourselves from
the chaos of unmaintainable code and
never-ending hot fixes we laid down a
set of principles principle number one
is don't write site-specific
conditionals in principle number two is
don't break the host page so let's start
with the first one one of the biggest
problems with writing an extension that
works across multiple hosts that each
one is different what if you need to
tweak your UI a little bit based on the
layout of different sites what if you
need the selectors that grab native
elements to be different on different
pages in the early days of your
extension especially if you're starting
out with a small subset of supported
sites like we were it can be really
tempting to let site-specific
conditionals creep into your codebase if
I'm on Gmail do a and if I'm on LinkedIn
do B but this is the path to madness
because not only does putting if-else is
everywhere in your code would make it
really hard to read but it's also good
to be an absolute nightmare to maintain
now every time you want to support a new
site you have to track down every place
scattered throughout your codebase where
you have site-specific logic and that
will be no fun at all so wherever you
possibly can you might try
your solutions in a generic way so they
work on every host page the key the key
thing here is code reuse the more of
your code that's reusable across all
sites the better and where that isn't
possible one option you can try is to
limit your site specific code to a
single configuration object one config
per site that has a defined API all the
rest of your code can then just
generically consume this site config
without worrying about which host sites
are on and that way if you want to add
support for a new site all you have to
do is fill in a single new site config
and you'll be good to go so let's see
this in action shall we I'm gonna exit
out of here and let's mirror our screen
okay so here we are in Gmail and I don't
know about you guys but there's just
something I really miss about writing on
my computer something that just feels
missing you know what I miss I miss
Clippy I don't want to build an
extension that brings Clippy back when
I'm writing my email so here we have a
Content script that's running in Gmail
let's see if we can get him into Yahoo 2
which apparently has no internet
connections great so let's look at some
code so here we are in our text editor
our code editor and this is the content
script that's running on Gmail and it's
really simple it just has three parts
first we're going to get our site config
next we're going to pull for mail
windows and then if we find a new mail
window we're going to append to Clippy
so let's break each of these down here
so right now we only support Gmail so we
only have one site config and this is
really simple it just has a single item
in it which is our mail window selector
and we want this in our site config
because this selector is gonna be
different on every site and this gives
us the chance to do the right selector
on per site basis so here in our get
site config it's really simple all we're
gonna do is we're going to get the
domain name off of the URL if it's one
of our supported domains we are going to
return the equivalent config next and
pull for mail windows
we have a set interval here really
simple we're going to consume that site
config and pull the selector off to pull
the Dom to see if we have any new mail
windows if we have a new one we're going
to mark it as found and then we're going
to append Clippy and then here in a pen
Clippy we are going to create an image
element we're going to specify the
source as our jiff we're gonna add a
little bit of styling give them a size
and then append them to the mail window
so I think that we're gonna be able to
get them working in Yahoo without too
many changes and let's see if we can get
that happening so here let's add Yahoo
as they supported domain it's gonna mail
yahoo.com and then we are going to
return a yahoo config and then let's
define that so here we're going to
mirror our config from Gmail and then I
cheated it and looked up what the
selector is so it's going to be editor
container so that was it let's see if
this worked so I'm going to refresh our
extension refresh the page I don't have
any internet that's unfortunate
let's connect and try that again and
there we go we've got Clippy
quick problem she's a little small
like in Gmail the mail windows smaller
so he seems like a good size but he or
she kind of gets drowned out so let's
see if we can use our site config to fix
it up so let's add some site-specific
styling so down here in append Clippy
instead of using this hard-coded value
let's consume our site config and define
a clippie size value there so up here in
Gmail let's do Clippy size is a five
pixels and over in Yahoo let's make him
120 so now everything worked according
to plan you should be a little bit
bigger before but I think we can do one
better so remember principle number one
if we can avoid site-specific code we
should because that way we can keep our
site configs as small as possible
and make it super easy to add new sites
in the future and really I think all we
want is for clip me to kind of be a
certain percentage of the mail windows
height so let's do that let's come back
to our code editor let's remove this
value off of the site config and then
down here and append Clippy let's use
our mail windows height dynamically to
decide how big Clippy should be so I'm
gonna get the mail windows height really
quick I'm gonna use get computed style
and pull the height property off of
there and then that is going to be a
string so let's parse it into a float
and then let's make Clippy let's make
him three tents the height of the mail
window so everything went according to
plan he should be exactly the same size
he was before great but now we're doing
it in a dynamic way that's going to work
on any host site awesome
all right let's go back to some slides
so now we've talked about how he might
fulfill principle number one let's talk
about principle number two don't break
the host page so this one seems obvious
but it's actually a little tricky to
follow if you're doing anything
involving adding UI to the page perhaps
a more specific way of wording it is
avoid modifying the host pages markup so
remember before how we talked about our
extension living in its own isolated
world it we can't see the host pages
JavaScript and they can't see us but the
one thing that is shared is the dumb and
if we go making changes to the Dom
especially mutating or deleting stuff
that's already there the host page won't
be expecting it because I don't even
know that we exist let's use a simple
example so here's part of a Dom tree
rendered by page it's just a paragraph
with a little bit of text now let's say
that we as an extension want to
highlight the word hello the name thing
we could try would be to delete the text
node that's in the paragraph and insert
two new ones we want a highlight span
containing the word hello and that a new
text node containing the word world
but we have a problem so it turns out
that this page was rendered using react
and frameworks like react really don't
like it when you go mucking with the Dom
behind their backs it's keeping a
virtual representation of the Dom in
memory and it's thinks that that text
node is there so let's say that react
goes through another render pass and it
wants to change the paragraph to say
hello Seattle best-case scenario is that
react blows away the whole paragraph
element and then replaces it with a new
one and that's kind of a bummer for us
because now our highlights gone but
worst case scenario is that reaction
just tries to replace that one text node
which is no longer there and it blows up
with a not found error so now we've
broken the page and thrown principle
number two out the window so this seems
bad highlighting text is kind of a core
experience of our product our text do
and if our Chrome extension can't add
inline spans around the host
mark Upton what are we supposed to do
well we did like many engineers before
us have done and made your own
whiteboards a lot and eventually we came
up with a different highlighting
solution entirely and that's how the
sandwich was born and despite it having
the stupidest code name ever
it is the crowning achievement of our
Chrome extension so we call our
highlighter the sandwich because it's
made up of lots of layers and these
layers which are all absolutely
positioned one on top of the other
give us fine-grained control over how we
render highlights on the page and they
do so in a way that doesn't touch the
native editor so let's say that the text
in the native editor looks like this but
because this is a rich text editor users
could do things like change the text
color or add some background color or
maybe change some font sizes and now
let's say that we as the extension want
to add some highlights to the page like
this a green highlight around our team
and orange highlight around connect with
you
so for added fun when you hover over a
highlight we also want to turn the text
white so in the sandwich the topmost
layer is our native editor so we want it
on top so that it picks up all the users
mouse keyboard events just like normal
and we're not going to touch its markup
at all the only thing we're gonna do to
it
is we're going to make it transparent
except for the cursor that way the user
will only see there's layers that we
render underneath directly behind the
native editor is our text copy this is
an exact duplicate of the native editor
just with all the background colors
hidden so when you're typing in an
editor that has our sandwich mounted on
it this is actually the text you're
going to see and because we own this
copy it's safe for us to modify its
markup to turn hovered text wait below
that is our highlight layer here we have
a bunch of color divs that are all sized
and positioned exactly so that they sit
behind the text that they're supposed to
be highlighting by getting the bounding
recs of the phrases that we want to
highlight we can calculate exactly where
we want to position these in the Dom in
last but not least we have our
background color copy this is the same
as the text copied just with all the
text colors hidden and the background
colors visible
and this allows us to draw highlights on
top of any background colors that's in
the markup so they don't get obscured
put it all together and you get this
beautifully highlighted text and someone
else's rich text editor with this
technique we really don't have to touch
the native editors markup at all so
we're much less likely to break the page
like with most things or a sandwich
Hilah Tyler came at a price it solved a
lot of our problems but it also made a
bunch of new ones for example when I say
that we made exact duplicates of the
native editor turned out to be way
harder than we thought it would be
uh-huh making a copy of a Domino's
contents as easy but making the copy
look exactly the same is not we ended up
using a combination of get computed
style and some specific style overrides
to get them to look right but oh man did
we hit a lot of bucks we'd get like one
pixel differences that throw off the
whole layout and cause all our highs to
get drawn on the wrong spots and we
eventually got a surrett out but oh it
was not super fun next we also had a
problem picking up Mouse events properly
so remember that we need our native
editor to be the top player so that the
user can type into it and make
selections but when we do that the mouse
events don't propagate down to the other
layers and we want those events so that
when you hover over a highlighted phrase
we can change its styling and open a
tooltip so to work around that we ended
up implementing our own mouse tracking
we put a mouse move listener on the
topmost element so that we could track
the cursor position and then from there
we can calculate if the mouse is within
the bounds of any of our highlights then
if the mouse moves into a highlight we
can pipe simulated mouse events down to
the lower layers as if it had happened
natively and this felt like a total hack
but we could not find a better way of
getting the mouse events to hit both
players at once so we also hit some
snags getting our sandwich layers to be
super positioned one on top of the other
this is a natural use case for absolute
positioning but in order for that to
work we need a parent node that's
positioned as well and remember
principle number two we don't want to
break the host page and if we go slap up
position relative on to a native parent
node we risk missing up the
pages layout so to solve this problem we
pulled in a technology called the shadow
Dom so the shadow Dom got us a bunch of
different benefits and talking about how
it works an easily fill up another
speaking slot here so I'll just be very
brief about why it helped us let's say
that this is a piece of the Dom that we
got from our host page and we're going
to call this the light Dom as opposed to
shadow Dom yeah so in our light Dom we
have a Nia parent node and it has a
child node which is our native editor so
the shadow Dom API lets us take our
parent node which we're now gonna call
the shadow host and we're gonna attach a
subtree that's gonna be hidden from the
main application within that subtree we
can render a div with position:relative
and then within that we can drop in our
original child node this is using a
feature of the shadow Dom called the
slot API which lets you insert light Dom
contents from the shadow host into the
shadow tree now we can add our
absolutely positioned sandwich layers as
siblings of the native editor and this
is great because to the application the
Dom tree still looks like that it still
thinks that the native editor is a
direct child of the shadow host but what
actually gets rendered to the pages that
so we can absolutely position to our
heart's desire and thus principle number
two is fulfilled so how did it all work
out where's our chrome extension to
success I probably wouldn't be here
talking to you today if it wasn't so let
me show you I'm going to mirror my
screen again and then let's come over
here so here we are in Gmail again and
now we are writing a recruiting mail so
let's turn on texia for chrome boom
beautifully highlighted text and someone
else's editor
we've got highlights in both the subject
line in the body we've got a score we
can do things like take suggestions so
here we have an orange phrase which
means that this is causing less people
to respond to my recruiting mails so
let's replace that well now it's a green
phrase which means it's going to attract
people and it the score updated we can
type in real-time in highlights will
update so if I say wow this
is great not only do highlights show up
in the text I just typed but all the
ones that are already there move over
and then because this is a rich text
editor let's do terrible things like
making the font big and adding some text
color and all that just kind of works so
because we wrote this not as a gmail
highlighter but as an editor highlighter
it also works in LinkedIn so here we are
recruiting the fantastic hosts of our
event today and you'll notice that it's
the exact same experience here as it was
in Gmail so we're really happy with this
for two reasons one we're not touching
the native editors markup so we're much
less likely to break the page and two
this is totally extensible we can use we
can drop this into basically any editor
in a work we're using those site configs
that we talked about earlier and so it's
really easy to expand out as text geo
grows into other domains alright let's
wrap this
okay so if there's anything I want you
guys to get out of this talk today these
three things fine obviously besides sick
memes those definitely gained those so
one a browser extension is an incredibly
powerful tool really the only limit to
what you can accomplish with them is
your imagination to writing code that
runs on someone else's site it's an
adjustment it's a mental shift in how
you approach problems there's gonna be a
whole mess of new challenges you haven't
ever had to think about before and three
keep the principles in mind
avoid hood site-specific code wherever
you can and don't break someone else's
page by meddling with their Dom trust me
you will thank yourself later so that's
it for me I really hope that after today
you're all inspired to go building an
extension a shot if you haven't done so
already there are some good resources at
the link here as well as the slides and
demo from today and if you have any
questions come find me either here or
online I'd tell you you could find me on
Twitter but that would be a lie because
I don't have one so email or github
works great thank you so much everybody
and happy building